probably searches coming in but Sen
hot-dogging right now yes it hot doggin
real quick
Sennheiser again now Derek is here yeah
that has a hot dog
all right if you if you think that your
position is worth buying Derek Metallica
tickets that's a wise move good to know
where your loyalties lie hot dog that
was smart you've attached yourself to a
winning horse here so he made a mistake
you just dark side over your
instructions really did serious hey come
on in hot dog what Mike is that no the
other one where this possible isn't
beside okay alright that's a jump over
there uh-huh
you ever make a decision in a moment
that you realize long-term is probably
not the smartest one in the world a
couple of times yeah you feel like that
happened today I don't know I'm running
out of breath I'm running around yeah
did you like you buy Derek's Metallica
tickets form no I'm about to I was about
to you were yeah why not I'll tell it to
a point I'll make you fine I got
everything let's bring Bravo yeah Bob
Odenkirk comment I thought just saying
I'm sorry
you like Bob Odenkirk hood yeah hey Bob
hey buddy how are you Sam I am I like
that I like hearing that
who anybody is any more that's rotating
hosts here manager that's hot dog nice
to meet you and what your mom and dad
call you hot dog I thought it was why
would they named you after that my
actual name is Jay but I don't know why
they call me hot dog here you don't know
why do they I'm kind of curious myself
you know your parents do did you have
like a great grandfather name hot dog
some my baby at Ellis Island nation's
name the hot dog you're a hot dog it's a
family necklace that's probably some of
the names from mr. show were from Jay
Johnson one of the writers and his mom
was a public school teacher and she kind
of would bring home these names like
famous Mortimer
her was someone's name wow really we
used yeah famous Mortimer surname is
done right now who has their name in
yeah show that's great
yes and Oh Queen Ella and snow Ella Bobo
these are real people but I win Ella I
saw Ella you always want to like to make
sure people are aware of that like as
they're watching mr. show you don't
understand this is finer than you could
possibly have
thank you you know yeah well it's real
just life life has lived in America hey
Molly and family you know it is a common
first name for families that didn't
speak English and they thought the
doctor had named their child
oh yeah oh and Molly and falafels my
life right now but they they they just
were the way it's explained to me is the
people were worried you know obviously
they didn't speak English and they
thought the doctor had chosen a name and
they didn't want to argue right so now I
will call a male in Somali I guess we'll
just go with the doctor then like he
seems to be a man of authority yeah can
you imagine like living that life where
like you're so afraid of people in
uniform yeah like you had a doctor just
like now the kids can be made out I
don't understand what I was like when my
daughter's damage from acid to take yeah
I get well we'll be the middle name you
know nicknames are cruel things I'm
sorry how it's not the worst it's not
the worst not know how dr. Sophy bag is
worth a value that word see bag thousand
dollars nickname oh my god not in good
spirits no not in good spirits today how
do you change that that's becomes the
challenge of your life you lay awake at
night going how do i how do I do
something Oh what if I just start eating
hamburgers then he I can become
hamburger yeah it's not egg is even
necessarily the worst of my nicknames
what's your least favorite nickname I
used to hate sick baby but I'm used to
it at this point
Oh baby that's kind of a punk rock thing
right so yeah yeah like oh like I'm a
sick baby yeah that lead singer sick
baby
Kozak
because he was premature and used to
vomit a lot yeah and he was sickly
hilarious exactly infant he really was a
baby how do you guys know that he told
us he he bragged about yeah you said you
guys may not know this but when I was
growing up the only reason I'm here is
because I survived I really thought it
was a tale of overwhelming four pounds
yeah yeah couldn't keep anything down
nothing now you can't get it out clearly
that's the best part of radios you find
out so much about and the little things
people like your premature thing oh
great let's humiliate them whatever it
is what nickname would you a do you
aspire to yeah maybe we could change
your name like when the champion
how about ampion champions not this yeah
like a horse yes nice and sweet but also
kind of great strength of good stock
good yeah how about hold on Alec is
playing yes that is going to be my new
Knick what's that he's trying to go to
see Metallica oh yeah he was panicking
while the show was on about buying
Metallica how do you still like
Metallica yell on from 25 so I mean I
didn't a fan I wasn't necessarily hey
ever heard of the KISS Army oh yeah I
never was in the KISS Army even on the
other guys I wish I had neighbors who
were in it and I I dodged that track
right you never join me I never joined I
was a fan I loved cat worship gifts I
never joined the KISS Army and that's
the program that great of a little
charity pageant right you know I don't
know why and I probably should have
I had sure that is sure you should have
gotten some yeah some certification you
know were you a kissing amp like no ah
boot camp in the KISS Army
uh no I I liked kiss yeah I like them
but I think God pop music is such a
strange thing the way it gets to you
cause like I had Boston's albums and I
guess I like poppier guitar II kind of
I guess you could say softer but not
like soft eventually I was waiting for
punk rock to happen and I love The
Replacements is my favorite band of all
time do you know the replacement I know
the name I don't know a lot of music
yeah that's my favorite man ever do you
like to Ramones I do I do when they get
everybody right huh after the Ramones
before now they were after they were
after
yeah so what'd you say sex pistols I
like a lot hilarious if I just have one
album yeah just one album I mean there's
like an odds and ends album that they
also put out called the great rock and
roll swindle which is some weird [ __ ] I
don't know where it came from I guess
there's a movie I've never seen but
anyway the Sex Pistols are hilarious and
a blast and yeah so but I think kiss
actually I liked later just like came to
appreciate them you know like what they
did the replacements do one kiss song
which one black dark black diamond yeah
they great wood on there like fourth
album okay thanks to closer that was a
closing song is also great that's a
great song yeah how do they write these
great songs these guys I think they were
underrated sometimes because the makeup
and the stage show and the crazy tongue
and the demon I think sometimes some of
the music was actually underrated they
were better than people gave like roses
just a solid great song yeah and then
what look I know you hate it but Beth I
love that that was much imagine they
could write that yeah commit to it
we have women Garth Brooks did covered
hard luck woman they ate right stuff
yeah I mean these are great songs
originally it was supposed to be back
though you know Oh gene Simmons tells us
what we think genes women came in here
and took full credit for Beth yeah I
mean those two Peter critical huh
because he said that Peter was dating
somebody named Rebecca and he wanted to
do is back what can I do you know
yeah and gene was like no no no you got
to change it to Beth and he goes and it
became a hit Oh [ __ ] yeah a numbers
tend to disagree on the hit I know yeah
that's interesting though that you
didn't have like Yuri laughter punk
comes around you're like oh this is what
it's like everything just seemed like
too humorous to me it was the makeup and
all right which write too much you know
so he couldn't hear the song through all
the makeup you know what I mean yeah oh
by the way am I am I dreaming of this
but was there a documentary about kiss
from a few years ago where gene Simmons
gets stuck in the on the pulley on the
hydraulic lift you know I'm talking
about there we know I know what you mean
by don't remember the documentary it's
like from like 6 years ago it's not that
long ago and there's a scene and I I
swear I saw this I didn't dream this
he's up above the crowd in a large arena
on a hydraulic wires and he yeah harness
failure and it gets stuck yeah and he
sees a crazy yelling get me down get me
down this is final to God of hellfire
once again ya better let him down please
and he spit blood he's just this is
great I need to stock harness failure do
you can turn the sound on over there on
the iPad but Wow Lexi get me down see
the thing is if you're stuck up there I
don't know what you yell but you
probably shouldn't yell get me down she
just
and then they unhook him yeah and he
would play god of thunder yeah that's
awesome no like a recovery itself
hilarious like it really strictly
illusion away he's not a demon at all oh
man the only a point you see Figures you
point it down they're cheering for him
but then easily yeah he's supposed to go
straight down and go he's going right
back god damn it wrong button oh no
that's crazy
someone got to scream died after that
it's so embarrassing we have to stall
for time yeah on the ruling on a harness
one how do you how do you do how does it
I don't see how it all works that they
can write these great songs that are
really just nice simple and well done
and then that get into that kind of
stuff well they look they were built to
be a mega rock band like Palmer family
says that was our goal right we wanted
to be the biggest loudest rock band in
the world they didn't they didn't want
you know so the songwriting stuff was
already there but that was a goal that
didn't it didn't just kind of act
guys really what they want it's also one
of those things whenever you're looking
to get attention like you know because a
lot of people can write great songs
they're looking to get attention they
create this thing and now everybody's
looking at them but you're right what
ends up happening is you can't go back
to being a good songwriter after that
but yeah it'll make very hard to that
without us on a coup stick like a
Nebraska yeah would it be great though
if they did how that would be an
acoustic they did unplug unplugged it
was good oh really yeah they did I might
like that album I might really like that
it was good yeah yeah but they never
were nearly as popular when they took
off the make up no I remember that
moment it was one of those things that's
kind of every tried stuff yeah right
they went back to it yeah what is this
movie you're doing girlfriend today
because I made a movie called
girlfriends day that the one of the
writers on mr. show Eric Hoffman wrote
with a guy named Phil zlata rimsky funny
funny script those two guys wrote and I
always stuck with me over the years it's
it has no social value at all it is not
a commentary on anything there's no
reason it needed to be met except it
made me laugh every time I picked it up
and it's a noir film it's like this
crazy story where I play a greeting card
writer who writes romance cards and
hasn't written a good one in years since
his wife left him and and then there's a
new holiday called girlfriends day and
there's a murder and that somebody want
the best card somebody's got to write a
great card for it and it's crazy but fun
and it's run right that's refreshing
like just something that well I just
thought this would be a cool movie so
yeah I mean I just sort of mess funny so
I made it yeah that's it I mean that's
the basic I mean you know because over
the years I've written many screenplays
right and you you have a reason for each
one right I really want to explore this
I want to tell share this personal thing
or and then this silly thing just keeps
popping up as like always making me
laugh you know what I mean it's one of
those ones once a year I'd pick it up
and read it and it would make me laugh
so Netflix is such a great place and I'm
I know people there and for
a low budget we made this film and and
I'm really proud of it it's really fun
when you write a screenplay okay I want
to do this thing on a greeting card do
you immediately start writing [ __ ] down
or do you like just bounce it around for
a while are you good at just sitting
down and go okay here's where it's going
to go well I'm no good at the thing
you're supposed to do which is outlining
the whole thing before you write a
single word I don't even understand how
that would ever work I've tried it a
million times yeah because how do you
know what happens in it how do you know
how the characters talk or what they do
if you don't write a scene or two you
know where you see them talking and you
feel the energy coming off they're a
conversation or incident or whatever so
I kind of do both I sit down and write a
scene if I just don't get Precious about
that's the key is just you see the scene
to start your movie usually people have
a great beginning like a first thing
yeah find a bag of money right to kids
find a bag of money just write the scene
don't get all you know Precious about it
write it out and now you and then set it
aside and then and then do your
brainstorming and see where that goes
but also try to pick up cues from what
you write like what the actual words
they used and how they talk to each
other and what the scene looked like and
what the vibe was try to you know that
can then inspire where the story goes I
but look I'm not a great screenwriter
I've written like probably 15 movies and
only one has been made this little one
although two others are good I'm all out
of hope for a couple of the other ones
like you know I think that's got
potential or do you look back yeah I
kind of [ __ ] yeah there's one an
adaptation of a book a novel the [ __ ] up
by Arthur nurses in a great great New
York novel and it's the best thing I've
ever written probably at all it's an
adaptation right but I messed around
with the story a bit and it's it's the
best thing I've written but I don't know
if it ever get made it's kind of set in
the 80s and that's hard when you they
always want movies set now stranger
things on Netflix that was fake set me
yeah yeah yeah
a great great series but anyway yeah
I've written and I'm keep writing them
is it easier to get at all easier to get
things made now at our Breaking Bad so
that kind of mainstream yeah well I mean
it's because it's international yes
because there's some value to it in
Europe and Australia and Latin America
that I it would make it easier for me to
make something that I'm in because that
the show Breaking Bad and better call
Saul had played around the world it's
amazing it really blows my mind because
I was always a cult you know fan base
and I was fine with that I loved mr.
show fans and the alternative comedy
scene fans that knew me and knew my work
and I used to feel have that feeling I
don't know Jim if you have the same
experience of like if I was in a fairly
large room of people I could like point
to the people and say that guy knows me
she knows me those two people you know
just from how they looked in their age
and yes and now it's more widespread
because these shows play to everyone
right yes I was ask you to like do you
ever sit back and realize like wow you
and part of one of the most respected
shows ever done I mean Breaking Bad
really is is critically other actors I
mean [ __ ] Hopkins said about Cranston
is the best acting he's ever seen like
it's respected like on the level of the
Sopranos and a few other shows yeah that
most people just never get it's some
yeah but so when you think about that
kind of thing you do think that it is
that that achievement is out of your
hands you know all you can ever do is
your best work and kind of push yourself
as hard as you can but also with what we
do whether it's a movie or TV show it
kind of has to come together and the
audience has to find it and there's
magic and luck involved
and you know when you hear the writers
from Breaking Bad talk about the
experience of writing it they always say
we didn't know where we were going we
didn't know what it would be we weren't
sure we have a general idea I mean
sometimes I doubt I don't believe these
guys Vince Gilligan and Peter Gould you
know
like how could you not know I just shot
a scene and better call Saul
there's no spoiler alert here because I
won't be specific but there's this
little item that I find it's in the
ceiling of a room it's a scene from like
years before the the episodes of the
stories main event takes place and it is
an item that exists inside of a shoe box
in the first scene of better call Saul
in my closet I open the closet there's a
shoe box and there's this one item in
there that they don't even acknowledge
but it's there you can see it out of the
corner of your eye and then here we are
in the 3rd season almost the end and
there's a flashback to a scene where we
see what's inside that thing that even I
was like wait did you want who's going
to notice it's amazing it's an amazing
almost yeah it is it is yeah and it just
comes from the writers contemplating
their work looking at the story looking
at every element what people are wearing
what's around them just the littlest
things in the in the world and and
finding meaning in them and bringing it
out when it's time they're not even in a
rush to do any of this stuff it's it's
thinking on a level that is a little bit
scary and maybe look I could never do it
we worked hard on our scenes on mr. show
right let me beat them up and stuff but
a certain point of the comi scene it's
funny or not let's move on right but
these guys really sit in that room and
contemplate the story and and Bob is
talking about of course I better call
Saul season 3 premieres April 10th 10
o'clock on AMC and but right now
girlfriends day which you wrote and
directed yeah I did not but I did it on
microphone Stephenson who directed two
documentaries one called best worst
movie you ever hear of it no well
Michael what was a child actor and he
was in a movie called troll 2 and it's
just a terrible night it's horrible
you ever see a dog you know I know you
get to Mike's next role too and any made
a documentary when he grew up about
about the making of that movie and the
people who made it he went back and
interviewed them and it's really great
yeah there's troll too isn't it more
interesting to see a documentary about a
shitty movie yeah at the island of dr.
Moreau yeah I don't want to see a
documentary but the Godfather I want to
see how the island of dr. Moreau were
trolling that's much more introspection
when the expectations are high then it
turns into a piece of [ __ ] I got control
getting here I'm good
because expendable yeah look at that
horrible and he may have a documentary
about that and then he made another one
called American scream and we just got
to know each other from these movies
that I saw of his and he directed a did
an amazing job of directing girlfriends
day on Netflix starting yesterday and
forever so watch it whenever you feel
like it don't you love that about
Netflix you can do out over it go go
watch it now we made a little movie Jim
it's some people are going to get it the
first time they watch it some people at
3:00 a.m. one night they can't sleep
they're going to press play and they're
going to get it and they're going to
love it you know it's a kind of quirky
thing but the fact that it just sits up
there you can go to it when you're ready
when you feel like it it's the greatest
thing ever 93 million people have
Netflix you know small movies to get an
audience in the end you people work so
hard to get like their opening weekend
get rid good reviews but in the end you
just want people to be able to see your
stuff yeah mr. shell when it ended we
couldn't get it put out on DVD we
couldn't get it in video stores it was
just gone and for years and and that
hurts more than anything more than
getting paid whatever you'd like to get
paid for your work but just that people
can see it after you make it so being up
on Netflix is great I'm thrilled and no
matter what you do you can promote it
well you know yeah it's on Netflix now
and if you like it you can promote it
for years of you want 10 o'clock
Saturday there's too much with with
other networks it definitely could just
be easier yeah there's working with the
Breaking Bad people in the back also
all people does that like influence you
as a writer yeah you're like I need more
nuanced [ __ ] yeah and it does it makes
you it gets you close to really great
writing and the kind of it what it
always makes me do is when I when I
write you know again I'm a sketch comedy
guy and that's something that I'm a
little hyper and I just want to get to
the funny idea and then make the most
out of it and run away but these guys
calm down slow down pay attention listen
to the characters notice the scene
what's what's happening here they think
on a deeper level and potentially it
will help me be a better writer myself
do you want to compare yourself in like
your own mindful short like Jesus cut
look what these guys oh yeah I look like
a oh yeah yeah yeah yeah not only that
it's not just that the quality of the
writing is that they they place a lot of
trust in the audience and you know as
comics and I'm not on the level of you
Jim where you can go in front of a club
crowd and battle with them for their
attentions I have to they want their
money back right yeah I've never come
close to that and I really respect that
courage and talent did you never do
stand-up yeah but what a kid I literally
got hired at Saturday Night Live as a
writer the day before I was supposed to
go on the road in the Midwest as an
opener oh okay I was doing stand-up
during the boom and making a little bit
of money as everybody could you could
all everybody could make twenty bucks a
show two shows a night or three and do
like you know there was discos had
comedy night on a Monday I could make
twenty bucks on a Monday night so I was
doing that while I was waiting tables
and I was just about to go do my first
week you probably know the Booker he was
a Midwest Booker back when we were both
starting I imagine we're about the same
age anyway I didn't go because I got
hired it's Saturday Night Live as a
writer so I never look I would have
never succeeded in that world
it's just too goddamn hard and with an
audience for me I I'm kinda like oh you
you're not liking this
oh well I'll leave then you don't have
to listen to me it's okay don't watch
somebody else's alright I never felt
that fight right that real comics have
to feel you know how many comics and
you're probably one of them who love to
tell stories about how they walked a
room you know believe it's genuine some
guys get caught in the trap of the
admired Bill Hicks who is doing that
with political stuff or whatever was you
say and they think that it's cool to
walk them on purpose only if it's a real
walk like you don't want to isolate them
on purpose and just go boy Christians
are content and look at a woman with a
crucifixion hope she walks yeah some
people walk in for they're really doing
Iraq and people just [ __ ] those
stories I love yeah yeah yeah but some
of them are that other story and that's
kind of the amazing thing to me is that
that vibe of like I'm not winning these
guys over some of them are leaving [ __ ]
them I'm gonna [ __ ] stand up here and
I'm going to say the worst [ __ ] I can
say and I'm going to love this I'm gonna
walk this room and you know we got to
once your bombing yeah then you like
that once your bombing you're like all
right we all get a new yeah happiness
that's amazing to me I don't have that I
don't have that what were we talking
about
I don't know we tell us something man up
yeah I never got that far into it well
we got it yeah they're telling us in
your ear that you have other stuff I
love Bob Baker having me on guys
girlfriends days of fun movie and I hope
you like it on Netflix right now right
now better call Saul April 10th comedian
great season Gus is coming back oh
that's good about good oh and others and
others really yeah right